تصريحات بريطانيه تعكر صفو الاجتماع
الثنائي بين الرئيس الصيني ونظيره الروسي
بينما كان الرجلان يستعدان لشرب نخب رخاء
ورفاهي بلديهما اعلنت مسؤوله في وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه عن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه
لكياف تتضمن هذه المره دبابات
الروسيه الحديثه ارسال اسلحه بمكونات
نوويه سيقابله رد ممثل يهدد الرئيس الروسي
علمنا ان المملكه المتحده لم تعلن عن
تسليم دبابات لاوكرانيا فحسب بل ايضا قضاء
تحويل
اذا حصل ذلك ستكون روسيا مضطره الى الرد
يبدو ان الغرب قرر بالفعل قتال روسيا حتى
اخر جندي اوكراني ليس فقط بالاقوال بل
بالافعال ايضا بوتين الذي كان يحذر من
تصاعد خطر اندلاع حرب نوويه منذ بدء
الهجوم على اوكرانيا دعا في خطاب مشترك مع
ضميره الصيني الى عدم اللجوء الى هذا
الخيار ان لا رابحه في اي حرب نوويه كما
حذر من توريد هذا النوع من الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا لا شيء يفاجئني اعلم تماما كيف
فقدوا الاحساس في كل ما يفعلوه وكيف تهدد
افعالهم الاستقرار في جميع انحاء العالم
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه او اي سلاح يحتوي
مواد اشعاعيه يشكل كارثه بيئيه وفق منظمه
الحمله من اجل نزع السلاح النووي
لبريطانيه وايضا كارثه صحيه تهدد بالدرجه
الاولى حياه الجنود الذين يستخدمونها
فبحسب برنامج الامم المتحده للبيئه يعتبر
اليورانيوم المستنفذ معدنا ثقيلا ملوثا
كيميائيا واشع